embattled EPA Administrator Scott Pruett
back in the headlines today after a new
report detailing questionable ties to
lobbyists and serious concerns about his
judgment dating back to Peru it's time
as a state senator in Oklahoma White
House legislative affairs director mark
short quickly responded Scott Pruett
doing a phenomenal job and the
president's happy with him in more
confidence yes there's an what would it
take for him to lose confidence uh Chuck
I'm that's hypothetical I don't know
right now Scott puts in a great job at
EPA we're sad to have him there remember
president Trump's historic election win
was driven in part by a drain the swamp
agenda an agenda we strongly support
here on the next revolution and in many
ways the president has delivered banning
officials from lobbying for foreign
governments after they leave the
administration and preventing them from
lobbying agencies where they once worked
President Trump has also cut regulations
which means less bureaucracy and that
means less opportunity for lobbying and
corruption but this whole agenda is
undermined when members of his own
administration don't live up to the
drain the swamp standards President
Trump
appointees abuse of power is this week's
swamp Watch
[Music]
we talk a lot on this show about
government officials cashing in on their
time in public service by becoming
lobbyists after they leave but the
revolving door works both ways and
despite president Trump's drain the
swamp agenda it's still happening one
government watchdog recently released a
study finding a shocking number of
former lobbyists now working in this
administration and regulating the same
interest they used to lobby for there
are a hundred and thirty three
appointees in the executive branch alone
who previously served as registered
lobbyists including 60 who did so within
just two years of joining the federal
government of those 60 36 had
specifically lobbied the agencies where
they now work and only six had attained
obtained the ethics waiver necessary to
make it legal
leaving 30 members of the executive
branch allegedly in violation of the
president's executive orders designed to
prevent such conflicts of interest one
of them is Keegan lennihan a senior
official at the Department of Health and
Human Services he formerly worked as a
lobbyist representing drug giant
McKesson Corporation and its affiliate
u.s. oncology in his current post he
advises the secretary who oversees the
agency in charge of creating national
drug policies isn't that convenient for
his form of paymaster's a separate study
found 184 former lobbyists working in
this administration including Leonard
Wolfson an official at the Department of
Housing and Urban Development turns out
that Wolfson formally lobbied for the
Mortgage Bankers Association and it's
not even his first time through the
revolving door he also worked in george
w bush's housing department from dealing
with housing financing government to
lobbying for housing finance and back to
the government that's the swamp right
there here's another one Rebekah Adcock
she's an official in the Department of
Agriculture she used to lobby that same
Department a senior director of
government affairs at CropLife America
before that she was director of
congressional relations for the American
Farm Bureau Federation where her
portfolio included USDA conservation
programs ie subsidies these conflicts of
interests are just one way that members
of the Trump administration are
undermining their bosses drain the swamp
agenda a number of higher-level
officials have abused their power in far
more public ways let's start with former
VA secretary David shokan who resigned
amid widespread controversy over a
taxpayer-funded trip to Europe with his
wife staff and security detail visiting
castles and attending a tennis match at
Wimbledon I hope he enjoyed the
strawberries and cream that you paid for
former Health and Human Services
Secretary Tom Price spent over a million
dollars of taxpayer money flying on
private and military jets at least
president Trump fired him then there's
Treasury Secretary Stephen minuchin
who's also spared no expense at your
expense when it comes to travel he's
reportedly spent nearly 1 million
dollars of department money to fly on
military aircraft in fact minuchin has
reportedly not flown on a single
commercial flight for business-related
travel since taking office looks like
minuchin a former Wall Street executive
with an estimated net worth of 300
million dollars got used to the
lifestyle of the wealthy elite and now
he wants hard-working American taxpayers
to continue to fund it unbelievably his
wife posted a photo of her and her
husband disembarking a taxpayer-funded
military plane while hashtagging her
designer clothing brands she also seemed
to relish being part of this photo of
cold hard cash with her husband's name
on it here's a hint his names on it
because he's the Treasury secretary it's
not your money it's ours but none of
president Trump's appointees have been
under more scrutiny for swampy behavior
than EPA chief Scott Pruett he also
likes to travel in style having spent
more than $100,000 on first-class
airfare tickets citing safety concerns
as justification as well as needs
$60,000 on charter and military jet
flights when Pruett requested enormous
pay raises for his staff including a
$29,000 raise for his scheduling
director the White House rejected the
request but Pruitt didn't let that stop
him he reportedly used an obscure
provision in the Safe Drinking Water Act
to force the raises through he's also
spent your money upgrading his office
conducting expensive security sweeps for
hidden listening devices and purchasing
sophisticated biometric locks for
additional security not to mention the
43,000 dollars spent to convert a
storage closet
to a soundproof booth where Pruitt could
make secure phone calls he's the head of
the Environmental Protection Agency not
the CIA worst of all he seems to be in
bed with swampy lobbyists almost
literally for a cup price rate Pruitt
rented a condo co-owned by the wife of
an energy lobbyist whose firm conducted
business before the EPA that same year
Office of Management and Budget Director
Mick Mulvaney recently promised to
investigate whether Pruitt violated
federal statutes with his exorbitant
spending but the last thing we need in
Washington is another investigation what
we need is for President Trump to take
the lead fire Scott Pruitt and throw out
the lobbyists from his administration
president Trump's drained the swamp
agenda is vital it helped him get
elected and it's a huge part of the
change that needs to happen in
Washington DC too many people there
still seem to think it's business as
usual President Trump show them they're
wrong and go drain that swamp